he hypnotizes two guys
[Applause]
the bounce pass gonna get ourselves a
timeout Kairi just mesmerizes everybody
and then a little bounce pass to Vasquez
rebounded defended tired at 68 Perry
splits the defense spins at home
[Applause]
it's a two-point game this Kyrie goes to
the basket switch back and forth with
the duel
[Music]
so so
why Tyrese is pure awesomeness on Conley
calling right there the souls coming
over that shot and they get surprised
and you got that open now picked up by
watch okay I want to see the game
yeah right before that saying he kept to
foreigners knees even ride for takeoff
but that that move right there I thought
the file was there you see it got a body
the short roll and now 3 of 17 from deep
miry gone full uncle drew on Toronto
just a great great score the ability to
stop step back hit a little fade he's
third in the league in offensive
rebounding at close to five a game
offensive rebound for Nyree in his bag
well that's what he's looking for he's
looking for daylight and he's going all
the way go away scam of the guy beats on
a basket
[Applause]
from it magical display we saw the other
night against Toronto look at this play
bike off the dribble doesn't even put
the second hand on it I mean on target
on the money and he wants his number in
the rafters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
unbelievable
we can do things with a basketball that
most people just dream of to wait that
long for this call to be made I mean
dribbling below the ankles yeah how are
you supposed to get down there you can't
hit on it and then he goes high off the
glass
[Music]
[Applause]
beautiful spin move right there by Kyrie
again we have two of the top five point
guards in the game going at it we just
heard Chris a little talk about he
waived everyone away so he can get the
penetration good shot my tights to get
back in the play that time and get the
deflection Rivers try the lava to compel
me we got a good one go and get some
popcorn baby behind look just a second
basket in the first five and a half
minutes
Kyrie banks it huh one foot fadeaway
look at this play one there's a counter
gets the body steps away one foot guys
incredible that free
Kyrie slips recovers throws it up Butler
with doggett defense on Irving Kyrie
kept his dribble alive tough shot
watch this shot watch as he gets down in
here he doesn't have anything but now
I'm gonna go right up with a little fade
not a great play what a touch you be now
it's he's so smooth never herky-jerky
never in a rush and that was great deep
intimate jazz looking for a two-for-one
Eirene
[Applause]
[Music]
I in the back and that left somebody in
the dirt
Rubio yeah the Rubio and well you gonna
tie it up with off with you tie it up
with often but Irving gets over the time
line drives underneath great pass to
Tatum look here yep and then right
around to break yeah Celtics
[Music]
three sweet
serving it for you I read to the basket
just throw it up for lob Williams
Oh put your head by the rim young fella